after going woke nascar condemns let's
go brandon chant
threatens to sue
use of slogan with its trademarks this
is a daily wire story nascar president
steve phelps has threatened to sue those
who use the word let's go brandon slogan
on merchandise merchandise featuring a
nascar trademark and has condemned the
use of the slogan claiming that nascar
does not want to be associated with
politics
we will pursue whoever is using the
slogan and get that stuff
phelp said that's not okay it's not okay
that you're using our trademarks
illegally regardless of whether we agree
with that position is i feel for brandon
phelps said i think unfortunately speaks
to the state of where we are as a
country we do not want to associate
ourselves with politics left or right we
obviously have and we've always had as a
sport a tremendous respect for the
office of the president no matter who is
sitting okay so can you imagine how
ludicrous
this is the president of nascar
are you kidding me to say we're going to
sue those who use the phrase let's go
brandon i i think the way i read it the
way i read it it's different though if
you uh tyler if you look up let's go
brandon merch
you'll see you'll see merch with the
nascar logo on it that i can get
let's go brandon that's not what he's
saying though no no that's not what he's
saying because you see uh let me just
delete the merch you mean to tell me
nascar sells a shirt saying let's go
brandon they don't okay but they but
there's companies here you see all these
shirts yeah okay i get this part that
that but that's not what he's talking
about stop stop stop that's not what
he's talking about that's not what he's
talking about he's not talking about you
know the color of the nascar logo he's
saying
politics yeah if you say the usage of
the nascar logo i get it he's saying
let's go brandon what are you talking
about what are you talking about you
can't use a phrase this to me has
everything to do with corporate versus
culture so what do i mean by that
culture wise
this is let's go brandon central good
luck
getting your your fan base to stop
saying let's go brandon like you don't
have to be the smartest uh sharpest tool
in the shed to understand that they are
the let's go brandon champions of the
world
now when you're a nascar audience 100
percent what percentage of the nas
guardians are
have you been to nascar races i've been
to one
um what percentage of you think the
nascar audience leans right 70 percent
75 i would say even higher than that
okay fine okay point it what number do
you think
let's call it 80 20. let's call it 80
20.
they ain't stopping the let's go brandon
chan that ain't stopping anytime soon
and you know what good for them free
speech baby america root for brandon all
you want on the other hand the corporate
side of things the sponsor side of
things not hear me out nobody
nobody is more beholden to their
sponsors than nascar every single car
they have has fifteen hundred sponsors
littered across the car every single car
has got corporate sponsor corporate
sponsor corporate sponsorship corporate
better approach what's that you're going
to say anybody that uses the word let's
go brandon we're coming after you what a
moral on
there
with their logo associated this is
again this has everything with culture
versus corporate okay
when you're talking trademarks whether
it was let's go brandon or f joe biden
or f trump if you're using nascar's logo
they're basically saying uh not so fast
i think that part he's one million
percent right to use nascar's
but that's not what he's saying he's
saying politics if you're using the
nascar logo you must stop if you're not
using a uh
nascar logo yeah then he can do whatever
he wants yeah leave
if you asked me which sport
is least likely to go woke
least likely
i'd put nascar at the top of that list
but it just shows that when you bring
i'd put you on corporate you think
you think you think the percentage of
guys on nascar being on the right
is higher than the percentage of people
in nba that are on the left
uh things are you saying players or
you're saying fans i think i think the
nba is 90 plus percent left players i
agree okay where drivers and nascar are
probably going to be 75 right i think
it's very even yeah
i think
it's
nascar tends to be a little more right a
lot more right for sure i don't disagree
for sure i don't deserve whether that's
80 or 90 who knows i'm sure there's a
poll out there
but secretly i think a lot of nba guys
um are a little more
middle
than than they would be portrayed
i think during the whole social justice
movement the bubble and everything that
was going out there yeah i think a lot
of people even if they didn't agree with
it were like all right i guess i gotta
be on board with this
the one guy that didn't kneel
or the one guy that um
he didn't know he didn't kneel for the
he didn't theo for this t-shirt exactly
and then he broke his knee yeah
that's a rough go the one the one that
what jonathan isaac
his jersey says yeah
yeah but
anyway what's the bottom line here with
this nascar thing you think that they're
just gonna they're not gonna embrace the
let's go brandon on their trade they
shouldn't first of all you should not
they they should not sell anything
nascar saying let's go brandon nascar
shouldn't number one they're not number
two you can't use somebody's logo so
anybody that's selling to use a nascar's
logo yeah absolutely you can do whatever
you want to do with it but people using
the phrase let's go brandon they're
going to use the phrase can't do nothing
without a doubt so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]